in this video we'll be talking about
metaplasia which is one type of cellular
adaptation so let's see what happens to
a cell when it undergoes an injury this
cell has undergone an injury so it is in
a stressed situation it would obviously
try to adapt to the condition and there
are different ways of adaptation some of
the adaptation we have looked at in
previous video like
hypertrophy which means increase in the
size of the cell cells hyperplasia which
means increase in the number of the
cells atrophy which means decrease in
the size of the cells and ultimately
metaplasia which simply means change in
the type of the cell not the number not
the size so metaplasia in short is one
type of cellular
adaptation so what is the ultimate goal
so basically if there is metaplasia cell
can overcome the injury or adapt B
better to overcome the stress that is
that it is undergoing and if the injury
is too much and it is so serious that
cell cannot take it then cell would have
to basically think about dying so
basically when the injury is
irreversible it would lead to necrosis
or apoptosis but many of the injuries
are reversible so cells can combat that
injury with specific adaptation method
so in this video we'll talk about
metaplasia metaplasia is a reversible
change in which one adult cell type for
example epithelial cell or maybe
mesenchimal cell is replaced by another
adult cell type so this is really
important type of adaptation for example
there was a Squamish epithelia which got
converted into these columnar or
cuboidal epithelia so this kind of
change is known as metaplasia so here
are few important points regarding
metaplasia this change occur in response
to a stimulus or
stress and we would see many examples
for that the metaplastic change in the
cell shape help in to adapt it better so
it's basically not only a change in
shape it's exactly the change in the
cell type for example cuboidal
epithelia and Squamish epithelia they
are totally different cell types right
so it's a reversible process sometimes
when the stress of the stimulus is
withdrawn the cell size and the cell
type can also be
restored question is what is the common
cause of
metaplasia so basically chronic
irritation inflammation can be a common
cause or trigger for metaplasia the body
responds to these kind of stressors by
replacing one cell type with another so
for example there is a man who smokes
daily he's a chain
smoker so in his respiratory tract
especi especially in the
Brony the epith respiratory epithelium
can get converted into stratified
Squamish epithelium in response to this
kind of chronic irritation from the
cigarette smoke this is an example of
pathologic
metaplasia another example is like G
people who have ESOP
so acid reflux problem they might
Experience One sort of
metaplasia here the normal esophagal
cells which is squamous epithelium will
get converted into columnar
epithelium up I mean upon
repetitive gastric acid reflux so this
kind of conversion helps to prevent the
harmful effect of gastric acid reflux
now it's important to note that sometime
metaplasia could also be a risk of
cancer but before that let me tell you
intestinal metaplasia is it's a
transformation of the cell lining of the
upper digestive tract into stomach or uh
basically into a intestin like
fate so it is intestinal metapa because
the cells can change to become more
intestin
like sometimes hpy infection is a
trigger
for uh this kind of non-neoplastic
change as I mentioned before sometimes
these metapa can also be a trigger for
formation of cancer imagine that same
Barett esophagus example so here is the
normal esophagal epithelium after
repeative acid reflux the epithelium
changes into specific cuboidal epithelia
it's basically known as bar esophagus if
the treatment of Cur is done properly
then it would be also reversible that
means normal epithelium would be
restored but if it is untreated and
there is a prolonged acid reflux in that
case dysplasia can occur and in the
dysplasic Barett esophagus there could
be a development of esophagal
adenocarcinoma so this is how we can
understand that basically metaplasia
could also turn into a cancer it's
important to note that metaplasia itself
is non neoplastic or non-cancerous it's
reversible change as well but a
prolonged untreated condition might lead
to cancer situation but also exception
exist apocrine metaplasia of the breast
does not increase the risk of cancer
apocrine metop of the Bliss refers refer
to the benign transformation of the
breast epithelial cell into the apocrine
characteristic but it doesn't turn into
a cancer like situation or doesn't
increase the risk of cancer as
well so another example of metaplasia is
vitamin A deficiency which can lead to
keratomalacia so basically the thin
Squamish lining of the
conjunctiva gets
keratinized and it becomes keratinized
quam epithelium so basically this is
another uh example of nutrient
deficiency induced
metaplasia so there are other examples
such as connective tissue metaplasia
where certain connective tissue gets
converted into different tissue like
bone tissue so this is also known as
oous
metaplasia there are muscular
metaplasia in this case what happens is
the skeletal muscle May undergo a
metaplasia and transform into a smooth
muscle so if we look into phys
physiology there are different examples
of metaplasia and one thing to remember
in this video that metaplasia is a
change of cell type and metop plaia also
occurs when there is certain kind of
stress or stimulus it cannot occur by
itself so we looked at specific examples
like epithelial metaplasia G Associated
metaplasia and also discussed how
metaplasia can also increase the risk of
cancer so I hope this video was useful
if you like this video give it a quick
thumbs up don't forget to like share and
subscribe and you can support our
Channel using super thanks you can
contribute using PTM PayPal UPI net
banking Etc see you in next
video